go to about six four six five even buddy
heal who's six six six seven six eight
that's lewis king oh metoo trying to
take
omaruyi's soul and oh we got a little no
fisticuffs happening here we don't want
to see that
[Applause]
[Music]
his tempers
a little bit
raw
and that's going to be an ejection
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
that's too clear
unhappy with him being so vulnerable in
the air felt like he was a foul that
could potentially injure him but
cooler head's got to prevail you landed
safely you can be upset you can say some
things
you can't go at a man's neck like that
omarouji being
escorted
by the coach
to the side here's ways under review
definitely a hard foul yeah and when
somebody's that vulnerable yes
we both played the game i mean
you feel
taken advantage of
even if that's not the intent sometimes
as they go to the monitor and review
this but mark you're a professional
right and you've got to carry yourself
as such in this setting there's so many
people watching you you represent an
organization your owner is here
you can't do stuff like that
they threw a right hand and that's going
to be
an automatic ejection
that was a punch it was a it was a tough
foul right it was a dirty foul you got
to call it what it is
you can't have that reaction
couldn't tell whether he connected from
that angle it looked like he did
from the other angle it looked like he
did connect with
omarouji
and i like but it's a shame it's ending
this way
i'm just glad omar rory didn't take it
another step further right
could have been even ugly